what's going on reject nation I'm Danny
Larusso
you know I'm Johnny Lord I am the darker
olive skin Italian one here and I would
watch the season 2 trailer for Cobra Kai
I am so excited for this this is one of
the biggest surprises of last year hands
down a sleeper hit reactions for all of
them are actually up on YouTube reaction
highlights I don't know they'll get
taken down anytime soon I wanted to take
this moment here to also clarify I did
put this out on our community page on
the real rejects in regards to Wayne and
another YouTube original show we were
covering that the reason we were able to
do that is because we had permission
from the social media marketing team to
do it the way we do here with the
reaction highlights included those
10-minute cuts but apparently there was
a giant miscommunication between them
and the ops team in regards to Wayne so
now those videos have been taken down
not on our end they've taken it down and
we can no longer cover it so people are
caught every single day I see new
comments that people go where's your
weigh-in reactions where's your rayon
reactions and that's why we can't do it
well try to do the same thing for Cobra
Kai if we can get permission worst case
scenario will be doing reaction stream
alongs over at our patreon page worst
case scenario a lot of times our
different departments different shows so
maybe the departments for Cobra Kai
we're cool with us doing it maybe we can
do it season two either way put that to
the side I want to just check out this
trailer right here let's get to it
oh okay so she's really alright eyes
back on the beach yeah
Oh
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I love the marketing for this because I
remember when the first trailer for the
first season came out I was like man
this seems very self-service yeah you
watch it you're like it was actually
very funny and then eventually when the
stakes really do come in they're very
much felt and if you have followed the
show and then now you're here watching
the season 2 trail you know damn well
there's gonna be a lot of comedy infused
there's also that thing of now when you
see the marketing for the stakes as
opposed to this is kind of really so
serious now it's like oh yeah doggie
dojo Percy Cobra gosh this is gonna be
crazy to guys especially where the first
season ends up I just have so many
questions I'm excited to get answers to
because the odds that these two guys are
at and with Danny Larusso starting his
own school for free yeah it's such a big
undercut I mean like you know Johnny's
struggling to get by I started to get by
but they liked the tournament last year
so I'm sure that sales and everything
and also that camaraderie with their
team has it's so weird to be like they
demonstrated a surprising amount of
prowess for knowing when to have heart
when to have humor like you said but
when to get serious and do that in an
appropriate way and so yeah like you're
so invested yes well they left off on a
lot of cool nuts I mean please go back
and watch our reactions for it because
they were total blast to do though but
like John Kriss returning at the end
which is a great stinger you see him
here it seemed like they have this shift
where the at the end of season one
Johnny was gonna be learning some stuff
because he really was learning a lot
about his behavior not wanting to be
like the man who taught him John Riis
now that John creases seems like he's
back in charge because he's the one who
had the Cobra Kai a label and it seems
like he is the one who is calling the
shots now especially when these training
them like in the in the woods or
something telling that girl to kick the
guy yeah so I imagine that this is going
to
a lot of emotional obstacles for him to
overcome some sort of wondering what
direction is it going to end in in terms
because Johnny Lawrence really is for me
at least with this show at the council
unique is the star of this show he is
the central focus and I feel like Daniel
Larusso is probably gonna be elevated a
little bit more to be equal lead in this
season because in the last one it seemed
like he was more of the supporting now I
feel like they're both gonna be up here
and it's gonna be cool because I mean
you really get heavily invested in the
Cobra Kai side of things but also get
really mess in the miyagi dojo Tsai
which are two very different types of
martial arts philosophical approaches
there's just so much to look forward to
in this season yeah yeah oh yeah well
and I I'm you know the mystery is
enticing me too because you know I mean
Johnny ends up on a pretty emotional
note on the last season it looks like
his heart may be changing but with his
old master back I gotta imagine that'll
be a main thrust of the drama of this
season is probably their ideologies
clashing him maybe wanting to kind of
fall back into the old dynamic with him
and kind of serve him and maybe learning
how to break out of that or something
like I really hope Johnny just doesn't
go back to being a straight-up dick well
I imagine mhm I think you like the first
half of the season at least the first
half he'll probably be struggling a hell
of a lot with that because there's a lot
of subconscious psychological
repercussions that come when the person
who influenced you the most in this
martial arts field is back in your life
back to taking over the mentorship and
everything like that and your enemies
like yeah entering your kid yeah for
free exactly like there's he's that's
why he's like I think the the real the
more the gravitas that comes from is
within Johnny Lawrence by the time you
get to I imagine another tournament
fight by the end of this season or
something like that because they're
obviously gonna be building to corporate
Iverson Miyagi dojo by the time you
build to that I imagine that's when like
the ultimate Johnny Lawrence arc will
come into play maybe they become free
cuz they kept teasing like little
nuggets in season one that they might
start getting a lord might start
becoming buds you know like these
drinking buddy Danny's taking sympathy
on him because you know as much as it's
a personal thing for john kreese to be
back for Johnny Lawrence it's also a
very personal thing for Daniel
Rousseau though because that dude is
like the Iron Fist of a very important
time in his young life yeah so I gotta
imagine his reaction to see increased
back wall so be probably something that
lights a fire under him for whatever you
know I don't know if it's the cause of
his starting the dojo of his own but you
know it'll definitely affect him for
sure and you know what I'm surprised by
we barely got any McGee hell yeah as
much as I like Robby grew on me over the
course of the season and the first few
times we saw him I didn't really care
for him but over time he really did grow
on me my hair like him just when he
stopped just being an at-risk youth he
got old yeah interesting and Samantha I
really did like to and I know that we
they kind of left off on a note of the
word is whatever high vocabulary word
I'm searching for here disarray just a
bad [ __ ]
yeah that's though or not disarray cuz
he wanted her back but he was evolving
into this that was that they know is
causing Johnny Lawrence it's a question
himself was watching the evolution of
Miguel and Miguel such an amine
character and I love his character and I
was pretty surprised by the lack of like
you get a lot of Robby and a lot of
Samantha in here but barely any Miguel
in this trailer yeah it makes me wonder
cuz I can't imagine he wouldn't be a
main character again but it is sort of
weird that he only gets very kind of
incidental moments here I kind of like
this flip reversal that we're getting
here I wish I could be good at this is
good at dissecting Marvel trailers as I
am if you notice when we need T's a
couple of training moments with them you
have the Miyagi dojo students are
insolent kind of like warehouse I mean
in the background is like Fernandez
Fernandez they're fighting each other
their training is something that's very
low it seems like we're the Cobra Kai
students were trained the Cobra Kai
students are training were like ruff
were ruff Macchio taken hey Romney cheer
out of nature like they've switched the
spots where they would be training
normally like I guess maybe there might
be something in terms of the influence
of having a lure
to fight like their environment or I
don't know someone that you know you
know maybe they were gonna do that thing
words like we have to understand the
mind if our enemy yeah yeah
and there's a lot of Beach moments to
Karate Kid man I don't in the first
season than they ever go to the beach
they go to that big old Lake I don't
remember a beach yeah but the beach
that's saying a famous Karate Kid
imagery balancing himself yeah the
beaches I'm very excited for the show
man I'm very excited for this show that
the first season was solid had great
cliffhangers
just made me really happy I'm excited to
see like the actors themselves too I
imagine they put they probably practiced
a lot of martial arts in between - Eve -
look even better yeah
further fight choreography so I love how
they all went into a tournament and most
of them are still white belts you don't
need a color belt to punch somebody in
the kneecap and I before we wrap this
video up I would like to give a page
from the day shout-out to first off on
her patreon where we do TV show reaction
stream alongs and reaction highlights
the footage included for several shows
go check out our patreon page right away
but a picture of the day shout out for a
man named JT JT the man from Hawaii you
know why I got to shout you out here
buddy
karate Japan it's all linked I think you
watched Cobra Kai JT you make me really
happy I feel like life feels a lot more
lively and you could probably put your
pee-pee inside a Blake Lively because
she makes you awfully horny it's his
name JT or is it abbreviate yes no other
letters and named stampers I think it
stands for something I don't know if
we've found that out I feel like he told
us and I just don't remember now I think
it's like Justin Theroux
Teresa and Justin yeah you said it first
of all yes and that Justin Theroux
I'm glad you get a hang out with
Jennifer Aniston and I love you but
we'll be talking with you soon on the
interwebs catch you soon anyway guys
subscribe to the react nation click the
notification bell and a new JT did do
karate for a while dude you should
audition to be in the show we'll see you
guys there